[Music]
Ede evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation got so long a walk
over here I'll say right at the start
that Mayor Newsom is a fan of Twitter
and so questions that come in via
Twitter will be sorted by his staff and
us and the really good ones will make it
up to the stage you would Twitter him at
Gavin Newsom that's G avi n ne WS o M
two other announcements basically one as
usual when we're here at the collar
there's a reception at the long now
foundation office shop Museum and party
pad just over there I should mention
that the next speaker Michael Pollan
will not be here but we'll be at the
Herbst theater downtown in the Civic
Center on May 5th mayors of the most
powerful politicians in America right up
there with County Supervisors and that
may be one of the reasons that of all
the political entities in America cities
pay the most attention to each other and
learn the most from each other it's
helpful if you have a young mayor who's
still learning it's helpful if you have
a mayor who likes to travel and it's
helpful if you have a mayor who can tell
you the things he's been learning which
we'll get tonight Gavin Newsom
thanks sir thank you thank you all
thanks I hope the I was young when I
started but I'm not so young anymore
anyway Stuart thank you very much for
the opportunity to be here and thank all
of you for taking the time to be here
today and if I sound a little more
exhausted than normal it's because I
started my day about 2:30 this morning I
was out in Washington DC and got up to
catch an early flight I was last night
or rather yesterday at a conference in
Washington DC and I had the great
privilege and pleasure to get on stage
and debate the future of the car
industry and the future of GM and
Chrysler little did I know that the
audience was primarily lobbyists from GM
and my comments apparently didn't go
over that well which made me feel very
good about what I had to say so I may
find myself talking a little bit more
about that because it does I think
linked into the context of the comments
that I wanted to make tonight and then
Stuart's gonna come up and we'll have a
chance to do a Q&A but I do want to
focus on the issue of sustainability as
is appropriate in the context of what
brings you together here for these
series of conversations and in that
context try to drill down the issue of
sustainability and environmental
framework and talk a little bit about
what we're doing in the context of the
word Stuart just advanced as it relates
to what I've seen happening across not
only the rest of the United States but
around the world if you can come back
just briefly to 2005 San Francisco
hosted a conference it was the first of
its kind 2005 marked the 60th
anniversary of the founding of the
United Nations here in the City and
County of San Francisco it also marked
the fact that the United Nations for the
first time in u.s. history decided to
have its World Environment Day in the
United States of America it was not easy
to find the UN and to peak its interest
in environmental stewardship in the last
decade or so but they thought the anchor
of the 60th anniversary would compel
them
to consider at least San Francisco in
the context of convening the World
Environment Day we challenge them to
think differently about the World
Environment Day and rather than just
hosting an afternoon session we said if
we can host a series of discussions in
fact hundreds of discussions over the
course of the week we think it could
have some impact we invited mayor's from
around the world in fact over a hundred
and twenty mayor's from every continent
imaginable flew out to the City and
County of San Francisco for this one
week of exchange and ideas
Al Gore himself showed up at UN rather
showed up in Union Square and showed his
video for the first time many of people
had heard about the slide show in the
video but no one had seen it and he
unveiled it there to a few hundred folks
and we started to really frame new
consciousness in the environmental
movement again 2004 2005 things tipped
dramatically it wasn't that long ago
that we were still debating though some
still are but we were significantly
debating the issue of global warming and
climate change and our consciousness was
to convene
really beginning to evolve we had the
opportunity to set forth the principles
what we called Accords and we sat down
and we tried to hammer these out and you
can imagine 120 mayor's from around the
world it's not easy to agree on a set of
policy principles but we ultimately
agreed on 21 policy principles and the
reason we thought it was appropriate to
have mayors and the reason that the UN
agreed to invite mayor's was for steward
self-evident and I hope too many of you
self-evident and to me was rather
important because it was less
self-evident at the time and that was
2005 also marked and again people have
disagreed if it was 2004 some have said
it's really 2006 2007 but we also
celebrated a milestone of sort and the
UN advanced it at that conference that
for the first time in human history more
people on the planet are living in urban
centres and cities than in rural and
suburban areas that we had hit that
point for first
time in human history now more people
living in cities a million to a million
and a half people every single week
moving into urban centers this mass
urbanization hundreds of millions of
people will be moving into cities just
in China alone in India and other parts
of the globe that the fact that the
majority of the Earth's population was
there was significant but even more
significant is we also mark the fact
that in 2005 already that fifty or so
percent of mankind was consuming in
those cities about 75 percent of all of
the Earth's natural resources and
polluting the earth by an equivalent
amount those numbers only going to grow
and so it marked a revelation for me in
a consciousness for me that if we're
gonna get serious about the environment
you're gonna get serious about
sustainability you've got to look at the
environment very differently than the
way I looked at it when I was raced out
here in San Francisco where my father
used to take me on trips to the Tuolumne
River and that's what I thought was the
environment when he was working for
friends of the Tuolumne River or when we
went out and did photographic work to
try to say the mountain lions which he
was very passionate down at Hunter's
Liggett in other places along this great
state that was to me the environment of
going up to see the redwoods was the
environment the idea that now the
environment was an urban setting
challenged a lot of us and as a
consequence of those Accords in that
consciousness everything now I'm focused
on almost exclusively not everything
almost exclusively is now the notion of
environmentalism in an urban setting and
changing the consciousness around what
we consume how we consume and what we
distribute or what we throw away and
what we waste and the like and so we set
forth after 2005 some very ambitious
goals now San Francisco has always been
a leader on so many issues and the
environment was no exception but the bar
was pretty low we had done some good
things but we hardly were in the
vanguard of environmental stewardship
internationally in the United States
arguably we were certainly in the top
tier but we weren't doing as much
as we should be and so we set forth a
strategy what we called San Francisco
Ford to get very very serious and as a
consequence we've made a lot of progress
again the bar is a little higher but I
still argue rot remarkably and
relatively low here's what we've done
and here's what we're doing and here's I
think how it relates to the conversation
hopefully we'll have this evening we set
forth some very ambitious goals to
dramatically look at our renewable
energy portfolio to begin to look at
where our energy consumption was coming
from be it transportation sector be it
the building sector we looked at our
waste distribution in terms of recycling
rates we started looking at public
transit versus private vehicles and the
like and we started making a series of
policy advancements that today include
the following the most aggressive green
building standards of any city in the
United States of America private sector
standards you want to build and private
construction you want to build anything
in San Francisco you've got to meet LEED
certifications most cities many cities
in fact Sandra's goes one of the first
require that for municipal purchasers a
rather municipal building so for example
we build a recreation center it's got a
meet LEED certification
now we're requiring anyone that builds
any new home or new office or any
commercial or industrial building and
Sanford's going to meet those same LEED
certifications goes up to LEED Gold in
just a few years we got very aggressive
as it relates to biodiesel and trying to
get out of the diesel business and we
converted our entire diesel fleet into
biodiesel in fact we not only did it for
public transit and people movers at the
zoo but we finally got public safety
involved in this we have fire engines
running on biodiesel we have ambulances
running on biodiesel we don't know of
another city in the United States that
has now advanced as comprehensively that
strategy we generate a lot of that
biodiesel through a grease cycle program
fats oils and grease we actually pick up
fats oils and grease from restaurants
and from universities and some large
companies in the Bay Area and we pick up
those fats oils agrees and we
recycle them and we put them back into
this what we call grease cycle program
which we also think is a model for the
rest of the country we reached much
deeper in terms of our recycling
strategies and finally reached whatsup
that a number that we never thought
imaginable 1996 we're at 35 percent
recycling which by the way was pretty
good few people had ever seen 50%
anywhere in the world and here we were
we had some ambitious goals to get to
70% and we finally hit that last year
the highest recycling rates anywhere in
the United States of America and we're
well on our way to hit 75% we hope by
the end of next year that's why we got
aggressive about styrofoam takeout
containers and banned them that's why we
got aggressive obviously Jared bloomfeld
who came up with this idea when he
visited Stewart to your point in Mari
head of the department environment when
he visited Ireland came up with the idea
of the plastic banks which ultimately
was advanced by Ross Mirkarimi at the
Board of Supervisors the original idea
was just to charge for the bags and
ultimately that failed in a negotiation
with the grocers Association they passed
some legislation behind our backs to
preempt cities from putting forward a
fee and as a consequence we decided just
to ban them outright in reaction to
their adacia sacked we don't do well
with lobbyists and say our lobbyists
don't do well with us in San Francisco
well you usually always do the opposite
a lobbyist shows up and I remind them
it's over we also went after water
bottles a billion of them a year and up
in our waste stream we believe they
based
no one's been around to prove it but
again it's 10,000 years Stewart
everything's 10,000 years these water
bottles apparently take 10,000 years to
biodegrade a billion of them a year in
California alone and end up in our
landfills and I don't know you're smart
people the idea that you buy Aquafina
and Dasani it's tap water
it's Coke and Pepsi that are in the
business of tap water and they actually
put it in bottles and then they charge
you five to 10 to 15,000 times more for
that same liter water then it would
cost you if you just turn on your tap in
the insidious part of it is that water
once it's put in their bottle is not as
regulated as the water that's in your
tap
so our waters safer than the water
you're getting in a water bottle yet I
know many of you we're driving over here
drinking out of one of those water
bottles because we're just so convenient
and we're so convinced that somehow it's
maybe it's not the water coming from a
chechi but it's my pipes from my old
apartment and that's the reason I need
to do it there's other strategies press
we can talk about that later
but that's why we got so aggressive on
those areas all part of our recycling
and the consciousness around that we got
very aggressive about solar as well when
you go around the world you'll realize
we're not doing much on solar at all and
when you have a country like Germany
doing more than the United States on
solar something is absolutely wrong
particularly a city like Berlin that
does more per capita than any other city
in the world and I don't know if any of
you been to Berlin I don't think they've
seen the Sun in the last two decades in
Berlin it was a sighting rumored in the
early 1980s yet they are doing more in
photovoltaics than anyone and so San
Francisco we decided to raise the bar
and we have now the most aggressive
rebate strategy local rebate solar
program of its type anywhere in the
United States of America and we also
have the largest municipal yone solar
program anywhere in the United States
which bar is here we're gonna raise it
even further next month actually in two
months we'll be doing a new installation
that's going to be even bigger than the
Moscone Center installation down at the
Sunset reservoir this extraordinary
installation that will raise again the
level of consciousness around solar we
have seen by the way almost a 400%
increase in backyard solar insolation
since our incentive program just nine or
so months ago it's been a phenomenal
success and I encourage all of you to
participate in this program we've also
been very aggressive as it relates to
this electric vehicle strategy and again
those were my comments and the
reflection
comments with General Motors GM came out
today with guess what their new SUV you
think I think you I was making that up
they came out with their new SUV is it
any wonder that Obama representing the
largest shareholder now in GM the
American people would say and I think
it's absolutely appropriate as a
shareholder
you should have shareholder rights say
with all due respect mr. Wagner it's
time for change wasn't just a tagline in
a campaign and we need to move in a
different direction because the proposal
and I read the plan Jennifer Granholm
was none too pleased the Michigan
Governor I think she's spectacular by
the way and I and I appreciate she's a
tough position as governor of Michigan
she was not too pleased either with my
comments and Jennifer said well no one
none of these politicians that are
criticizing GM or Chrysler have read the
plan so I made sure before I got in to
the seminar to read the plan and I read
it and by the way I don't know if you
knew this in the plan it doesn't just
talk about your money to bail them out
it talks about foreign governments doing
the same they have six plus billion
dollars they're counting on from other
countries that's in their plan and
they're very proud of noting that in
their plan by 2012 they're committing to
have 14 different models of hybrids and
you say well that's pretty good until
you think for a moment wait a second
hybrids hybrids came out in 1900 in 96
in 1997 that's yesterday's technology
that's hardly tomorrow's technology
that's not game-changing technology it's
the oldest adage in the world I think it
was Michelangelo said it says the
biggest risk is not that you aim too
high and miss it it's that you aim too
low and reach it and those are the plans
right now the big three and certainly GM
and Chrysler you saw the same week that
that change was made at GM that in the
front page appropriately of the New York
Times was the announcement that China is
moving forward with an aggressive
not hybrid strategy but plug-in hybrid
strategy to electrify their fleet which
should have put shivers in all of our
backs because the reality is that's the
game changing technology is electrifying
the vehicle fleet that's the opportunity
to truly promote real energy
independence and you get serious about
what that means from the environmental
perspective from foreign policy and from
a domestic perspective in terms of the
jobs that we are promoting jobs of the
future in this green tech sector plug-in
hybrids so what San Francisco doing we
want to be the epicenter we want to be
the world's headquarters for electric
vehicles I happen to think plug-in
hybrids are a game changer the real game
changer is full electric that's
something that I have been promoting for
years and I've walked my talk I was one
of those people that had the original
electric vehicle from Saturn which was
GM that they recalled the ev1 and they
destroyed the technology and by the way
it's the same guy was fired that
destroyed that technology and they
instead invested in more minivans and
SUVs and heavier trucks where they
didn't have to meet those cafe standards
those corporate average full efficiency
standards so they had a bigger profit
margin and perversely because of the
lobbyists and because of our fabled
politician not just Republicans
Democrats representing Michigan we
allowed this to happen
and so we were own worst enemy we have
not necessarily seen GM come up with
anything particularly exciting since
that old technology which was tomorrow's
technology that there still today not
arguing for remarkably there
rhetorically discussing but they're not
advancing in any meaningful way so we
want to be front and center and so what
we've done is we're building out a
ubiquitous infrastructure and you say
well electric vehicles are great but
you're having two reservations if the
electricity comes from coal that's
terrible I want you just substituting
one horrible thing for another horrible
thing and we'll talk about that and
that's totally legit
the second argument is range you know I
got it I got kids and need a bigger car
and we go up to Lake Tahoe periodically
and I can go one way but I'm not sure I
can get back so we need an
infrastructure and so we're addressing
both this way we'll start with the
latter not the former range is a
limiting challenge with your car the one
you probably drove here tonight you have
to have gas you actually have to go and
get your tank filled up if you don't
you're stranded in the middle of the
street and that's happened probably to
most of us in this room no different
than a electric vehicle so you've come
to accept we've got about 169 gas
stations all across the United States
America that one's gonna be within
proximity to another or at least within
a range that can get you where you want
to go from not only points all across
the Bay Area and north and south
Southern California but across this
country that's the idea for electric
vehicles to build out instead of gas
stations switch stations where you can
do exactly what you do with your cell
phone when you get a new battery you can
flip that battery out and replace it
with a brand new battery in less time
than it takes to fill up a tank of gas
true convenience now the range issue has
dramatically addressed or you can look
at the whole idea of a car like you look
at your cell phone and you say well what
does that mean well first of all I don't
know that any of you know how long your
cell phone takes to recharge because
most of you do it at night most likely
same idea would be with your car which
fully recharge and incidentally it will
be recharging when you have the lightest
load so it levels out the load and
that's a light load with a higher
renewable portfolio in those off-peak
hours that's for the other part of my
commentary but what is an extraordinary
opportunity and this is not just idle
speculation this is happening it's
happening in Israel it will be happening
in Denmark it will be happening in
Australia and Portugal and I hope it
will be happening out here in our own
backyard in Northern California is to
look at the car like you do your cell
phone for a different reason you buy
minutes
you buy plans you get prepaid cards
maybe for your kids you don't want to
have unlimited plan you have restricted
plans imagine looking at a vehicle like
you do your cell phone and instead of
buying minutes you buy miles you
separate the idea same thing the phone
companies have done the actual phone is
nothing they're giving those phones away
the hardware it's really become a
software strategy same idea presents
itself if we reimagine the car industry
and look at it accordingly separate the
battery and the energy ie electricity
from the actual physical car how people
build cars and have a strategy for
software strategy for electricity for
the oil in this case as the alternative
and by miles instead of buying minutes
that's what a company called better
place is promoting and that's what
they're doing with shamone first our own
Perez in Israel as we speak that's what
they're doing in just a few weeks in
Japan when they're building out that
first switch station that I talked about
that will be in commercial production
this is an opportunity to completely
rethink this industry and this is what's
missing completely at GM and Chrysler
and the big three right now but this is
what's happening out here in California
state of dreamers and doers of
entrepreneurs of innovators always on
the leading and cutting edge of new
ideas Tesla motor 0 to 60 in four
seconds completely green 100% electric
vehicle company out here in the South
Bay it's happening as we speak
completely allowing you to reimagine
what the old electric vehicle should be
about it's not about performance people
said well now you have car that performs
the higher clip than even a new Ferrari
or Porsche in terms of how quick and
efficient is with half the moving parts
so it doesn't have to be maintained as
much or as significantly much more
efficient because it has half the moving
parts electricity where's it come from
well in San Francisco we built out some
charging stations you can go to our
garages you're going to be going a lot
more places in the next
few years we want to build out tens of
thousands of charging stations
throughout our city I want you to
ultimately go to a parking meter and
rather than just paying more for your
parking meter you may get a little more
in this case and that is you can plug in
to that parking meter we're gonna be
rolling out 25 percent of all our
parking meters in San Francisco we're
moving away from those ugly polls and
we're getting rid of them and we're
gonna have boxes and we're gonna be the
first city with congestion pricing
strategies for parking and new
technology where you actually have
sensors underneath the parking space and
when the car is there you'll know on
your PDA or your home computer or in a
car's not there you'll know that space
is available and you'll actually be able
to check it ahead of time and we'll
price it based upon strategy of
congestion so be more expensive to park
during peak time much less expensive
during off-peak time in order to
encourage that our peak opportunity to
spend more and to level out that demand
model 25% and we're starting this year
it's called SF Park but we want to
incorporate a strategy as well so you
can plug in to some of these parking
meters the good thing from San Francisco
is all our municipal energy is
completely green and renewable comes
from a chechi
may not have been my first choice back
in the turn of century to dam a
beautiful part of the Yosemite Valley
but it was done and we've been taking
advantage of it all our municipal load
all our lights in the city are run off
that about 96 percent to be precise so
every time you park in a garage and you
take advantage of that plug in one of
our municipal guys that's a green energy
that's not coal fifty percent of
electricity United States comes from
coal by nineteen percent comes from
natural gas 19 percent comes from
nuclear about nine percent comes from
hydro wind and solar and three percent
still remarkably of electricity comes
from oil so the more we increase that
mix then we'll substantially decrease
obviously the negative side of using
electricity that doesn't come from a
renewable source the opportunity though
is we
baseline renewable standards as
California's advanced where we're
currently 12% of our energy portfolio is
renewable we're going up to 33 percent
by 2020 we're going to substantially
improve that mix and substantially
reduce greenhouse gas emissions
accordingly one point though of good
news even if you use coal generated
electricity it's more efficient than
using oil because of the point I just
made the efficiency of electric vehicles
is dramatic compared to an to combustion
engines less moving parts so that
efficiency even on an equivalency of
coal versus oil you have a lower amount
of greenhouse gas emission or
specifically carbon dioxide that is
being emitted in that electric vehicle
something else that is a myth that
somehow they're equivalent they're not
because of the efficiency again of an
electric vehicle so even at the
worst-case scenario we're doing better
in terms of the environment these are
just some areas on the environment that
I wanted to advance for the purpose
perhaps of a dialogue with Stuart and
all of you this evening that at least
enliven my senses and motivate me and
have gotten me to believe we can do more
and better quickly what does that mean
we're about to require composting only
big city in the United States America to
do that we've gotten very serious again
I'm Michael Pollan in here which is
spectacular
he's one of my my heroes and Alice
Waters why put that big remember that
Victory Garden we put a big vegetable
garden in front of City Hall and now
you're seeing folks in Washington DC and
Michelle Obama first lady Obama doing
one and now you've got Maria Shriver
doing one up in Sacramento I remember
when we put our garden in Willie Brown
chastised me and said what's he gonna
you're gonna have cows and horses next
out they're missing the point that this
was about raising the environmental
consciousness about what we eat and
where we get the food you're gonna go
home tonight and the chances are that
the average plate and this may be this
certainly is not an average audience but
in San Francisco the average consume
meal tonight
I've traveled some 1,400 miles to the
plate yet 80% of everything we need is
produced within a hundred square mile
radius of that Golden Gate Bridge how
does that make sense the most vibrant
agricultural region arguably anywhere in
the world and we're fresh
well we're freezing things fresh frozen
sending them overseas to process to have
them come back at the marina Safeway it
makes no sense whatsoever and so we're
really trying to challenge people about
this urban rural connection in terms of
agriculture and food and so we have a
whole new food strategy it's all part of
our healthcare strategy as you know
we're the only city in the United States
America with a universal health care
plan that's actually implemented for 64%
of people comprehensive universal health
care and now we're focusing on investing
in people's health as opposed to
treating their sickness which means
we're focusing on what they eat
their wellness how they exercise what
they're drinking and that's not just
alcohol that's big gulps in the morning
that four-year-olds are drinking and
that's why we have this obesity numbers
that came out for four-year-olds
yesterday which should have stopped all
the presses as well which are of course
increasing health care costs for all of
you type 2 diabetes and all these
chronic diseases because of that eating
and drinking problem so that's another
big focus and the carbon footprint
associated with food and how it travels
and how it's manufactured and now it's
produced it's another area of this
environmental consciousness for a
sustainable city that we're also arguing
for and also advancing we also and just
I'll close and bring Stuart up and we
can talk about all kinds of other topics
that I think are pertinent to a
sustainable city but because we're here
I think it's important to know we just
we've spent about four years on this
five miles off the coast of Ocean Beach
in a few years you're going to have the
first commercial scaled wave generation
project or generating project in
California's history the vision and idea
is to get rid of those 33 polluting oil
platforms now this may be a little
addition but I like it nonetheless and
replace them with wave
generation platforms and harness mother
nature's extraordinary energy she has
been waiting for us all these millennia
saying what is wrong with you people
you're drilling to take out things that
have been sequestered and are safe and
now you're destroying your planet when
here I am every single day providing
everything you need five miles off the
coast wave generating platform finally
got our permit in after years and years
of studies and we want to be the first
big commercial application of that new
technology and second right below the
Golden Gate Bridge in fact the studies
show it's on the northern part this new
Doppler radar strategy take an inverted
wind farm or rather take idea of a wind
farm and put it underwater and now
harness all the energy in that tidal
flow think about the mouth of the the
Golden Gate the bay it's relatively
small you've got this great energy that
comes in in out 24/7 all of that dense
energy being wasted again you have the
opportunity to do what's been done in
other countries around the world and
that's harness that energy flow by
bringing in these wind turbines and
they're not really wind turbines but
that's kind of idea in bringing them in
underwater so again we've been spending
years on this one this one's become more
complicated a lot of environmental
concerns if you have big turbines and
planked in coming in and seals and sea
lions and who knows what else getting
sucked up and consumed and we're working
through all those issues but we also
want to be front and center on all of
that so again those are things just for
the past the present and I think a more
sustainable and enlivening future final
point on this this thing the opportunity
is self-evident you've you've probably
all of you now by now have heard of Van
Jones vans showed up he's now the
advisor for Obama he started this
organization called green for all a
number of years ago he started it at the
World Environment Day in 2005 he just
had this separate conference because he
said I remember him yelling and
screaming at me said hey all you guys
look like you mayor
so what do you mean look like me they
say you're all white environmental
movement's just two white
he didn't literally say this buddy
implied and he was not wrong it's true
it's all environmental all these years
it's it's you know it's a certain group
of folks and he was making the case what
about all of us and he held this little
side meeting it was down there I think
it was it it was in fact I remembers at
the Metreon Sony Metron was the only
room he can get and he had this
remarkable conference in this discussion
probably about 70 people there won a
huge crowd and he started talking about
twinning the opportunity to deal with
environmental justice social justice
broadly speaking income inequality which
at the time had grown acutely under the
Bush administration and to start
twinning the opportunities to create
real green collar jobs and that's when
green for all and this organization
really started to take shape and here he
is now advising President Obama just a
few years later wrote this really
wonderful book which I encourage you to
pick up where he really lays out a
blueprint to deal not just with one
issue the environment not just deal with
two issues jobs and the economy but to
deal with that big third and that is
locking people into this new sustainable
future that have been locked out of the
old industrial past and making sure we
reconcile the issue of race in
relationship the environment four out of
five toxic waste dumps primarily in
african-american communities asthma
rates here we are on the nine four one
two three dis a zip code asthma rates
are literally eight times higher in the
bayview-hunters point than where we're
sitting here today in the same city
where you have two polluting power
plants now one because we shut down
Bayview Hunters Point plant we're still
trying to work to get Potrero plant torn
down that's a serious issue and this is
the great opportunity of this
environmental movement is to twin these
issues in a substantive way so green
collar jobs these jobs that we talk a
lot about this is also extraordinarily
important and I'll just note this when
we did our solar program we
did it with this in mind if you want to
do solar you'll get $2,000 from the city
just right off the bat if you want to do
solar and you want more money from the
city then you have the opportunity to
hire from one of our workforce training
programs and we'll give you $3,000 but
if you want to even get more hire from
one of our workforce training programs
from employees that live in a certain
zip code in San Francisco and we'll get
you to $4,000 whole idea of
incentivizing a focus and attention to
address this issue in a substantive way
and by the way the overwhelming majority
of people are doing just that they
recognize the opportunity to do the
right thing it makes a lot of sense for
them directly as well and remember those
rebates go up to $10,000 so I want you
to think about that as you leave tonight
for those of you that have not put solar
up or your landlord has not put solar up
go on Solar map SF dot org you can
actually map your roof and we'll have
all of these incentives right there the
million solar roof initiative at the
state federal tax credits everything you
need to get it done and then you say
wait a second there's still a gap and
I'm barely holding on on my job or you
wait 30 days we'll have the most
aggressive Berkeley
eat your heart out I love Tom bass what
you've done ain't seen nothing yet we're
about to have the most expansive
strategy to pay the Delta and the
difference and to put it on your taxes
or rather put it on your property tax
not just for solar we're gonna allow you
to finance without $1 out of pocket and
amortized over the life of your loans
the ability to do energy efficiency all
kinds of weatherization boiler
replacements deal with showerheads and
toilets as well as solar this is the
next very exciting part and then link
again those dollars into these workforce
training green collar job focus
environmental justice social justice
focus again as part of this new
narrative of interdependence on all of
these issues which again I think is a
big part of Stewart's
and his purpose and his foundational
beliefs that I think drive most of your
passions in this room so I hope those
things at least get you a thicken for
the purpose of conversation tonight
I am very enthusiastic and I mean this
with sincerity about the future
I think we're barely scratching the
surface I have great expectation that we
can continue to do more and do better
scale these things they can be scaled
conversation has changed people are
experimenting all over the country Sam
Adams who's the new mayor of Portland
just announced a electric vehicle war
against San Francisco which was New York
Times picked up it was just great
bloomberg stole our taxicab idea when he
converted his tabs to green cabs we did
that a year prior I announced it on
local cable channel 26 that's probably
why you didn't hear it he announced it
on there but he announced it on The
Today Show that's why you did he's got a
bigger pie even he's on the cover I was
taking Amtrak from New York to DC and
there's Bloomberg on the cover of the
Amtrak magazine and it's all about his
new urban wind strategy God is my
witness he stole that from us three
months ago we had a big piece about our
urban wind task force and he announces
it gets in the AP and in the article I
said well what new idea does he have
that we haven't done it's just well it's
just an idea and they've got a ten page
spread about this brilliant visionary
mayor in Bloomberg my point only saying
this is I'm proud that he's doing it and
we're very excited that this competition
is taking shape in the environment and
it's a very healthy competition and
apparently Sam has raised the bar in
Portland and by the way and this is my
final word Stewart
Portland is particularly distressing
because Portland every single year is
the number one sustainable city in the
United States to San Francisco's just I
mean five years in a row second runner
up every year San Francisco number two
Portland number one so we're going after
Portland enough of Portland you're from
Portland
you know enough give us a break we don't
want to be runner
up forever but again it's all about
raising the bar and raising
consciousness and this is kind of a race
to the top not a race to the bottom and
it's a very very good thing and that
does tie in to those other 120 mayor's
that sign these Accords even the mayor
of Tehran we had diplomatic
relationships with Tehran going back
years ago ironically that these mayor's
are paying attention and they are
holding themselves accountable and they
are on the front lines of this and
that's why again I expressed a lot of
hope and a lot of optimism and I really
do think the best is yet to come so
thank you all very very much
thank you for making comparison as the
cities say a little more about your
travels where you've been both before
and and since you became mayor and what
you've noticed for good and for bad in
other cities around the world I was just
I'm I was on my honeymoon which
apparently I didn't really think it
through because when I go someplace as
mayor I always want to meet with the
mayor and apparently it wasn't the best
choice when you're you just got married
and you're on your honeymoon to spend
time focusing on transportation in Kenya
but that's what we did we we we did the
usual safari day and then I said I need
to spend the day with the mayor in
Nairobi and so we spent a day there and
it just you triggered that in my mind
this is a place that no public transit
whatsoever I mean two-thirds our public
transit is running on alternative energy
already we have a goal by 2020 to be
completely renewable hundred percent
green we have now the third largest
fleet these are actual needs not per
capita adjusted and we're not a huge
city but the third largest hybrid fleet
in America and we added that biodiesel
component which reduces our NOx
emissions about by about 90 percent
which was a new part of the portfolio
last year and we've got some other very
ambitious plans in the next few years in
spite of big budget constraints which I
know are driving everyone crazy because
we're concerned about raising the fares
and other fees and fines and none of
those decisions by the way have been
made so those that have been critical or
right to criticize don't worry we
haven't done anything yet I can't
promise we won't but the contrast was so
stark you cannot run a world-class urban
center without a world-class public
transit system
there's no way to accommodate the growth
of these cities in the mass urbanization
without a dynamic public transit system
we have tried to link the public transit
to the taxicab industry we've put that
cab companies now under our new
Metropolitan Transportation agency we
put parking and traffic under our
metropolitan transportation agency
because you can't drive the streets of a
hence urban core unless you're moving
double-parked cars off the streets can
you imagine I mean we'll never navigate
in a dense urban environment San
Francisco if you've got trucks and
personal vehicles every two blocks in
the way so you've got a link the parking
and traffic discipline obviously to the
public transit discipline we're offering
considerations on congestion pricing not
just for parking meters but overall in
the city along the lines of Singapore
which is another model city Stockholm
that advanced it and certainly London
though it's being pulled back in London
New York Mayor Bloomberg sorry and so
those examples of City play in that
radius you said London's pulling back a
little bit and how does it actually play
out and are they different in Stockholm
to Singapore in these place well
Singapore invented this idea started in
Singapore everyone focused on Mayor
Livingston in London you've got a new
mayor that's actually pulling back they
actually expanded their congestion
pricing in London and that expansions
being pulled back to the original
downtown core it hasn't it depends on
how you want to analyze the studies and
I've studied this a lot in London it's
become accepted but it's hardly popular
it's costly and not all the money has
gone to what they promised it would go
to which is public transit and that's
where you get in trouble not following
through on your promises stockholm did
it then had a national revolt in
revolution sort of pulled back and now
they're trying to pull forward again and
you saw Bloomberg tried to do in New
York and got crushed you you should note
that the money were getting for our
parking meters comes from the urban
partnership dollars that Bloomberg lost
when he lost the congestion pricing
money so that was actually New York's
dollars that we were able to pull into
San Francisco for a different kind of
congestion strategy which was a parking
meter strategy as opposed to a car
strategy but I bring up those cities in
contrast to a place like Nairobi where
you could see best practices or new
ideas and innovation taking shape and
then you could just see just the
devastation the health devastation the
congestion the chaos that exists
in cities around the world like Nairobi
and it's a point of real concern public
transit in the relationship the
environment is foundational and
principles did you happen to get out to
keeper the big squatter city next to
Nairobi no idea I was there about 10-15
years ago and a lot I still photographs
actually in my house then I took it was
it's it's alarming we had one question
from Kevin Kelly in terms of
infrastructure which city in the world
other than this one you most admire in
terms of the infrastructure well I
admire for the wrong reasons but I've
been to Shanghai a few times in the last
few years and it's just mesmerizing just
extraordinary these mega cities that are
going up and they're doing Meg live in
terms of high-speed rail there moved to
the next stage of high-speed rail you go
from the airport into Shanghai in 20
plus minutes and it's literally magnetic
levitation which deals with no friction
obviously on the rails we're pushing
very passionately and aggressively to
build the Grand Central Station of the
west coast of the United States here in
the City and County of San Francisco at
the Transbay terminal we want the
terminus of the high-speed rail to end
in the downtown core so you go from San
Francisco to LA in two hours and 26
minutes downtown to downtown candidly
that's technology that's 30 years old
it's the electrification this is the
next phase technology the challenge
Shanghai is having is that it's been
very costly in terms of maintenance but
it's mesmerizing to see it as is
mesmerizing to see the density that's
going up in these skyscrapers and so
it's cities like that that I've been
wildly impressed now it's not a model
city from my perspective but there's
components that do I think lend
themselves again density focus on
transit oriented development focus on
building a connection and regional
connection inner city connections in
terms of high-speed rail systems not
these old antiquated systems that we
have throughout the United States it's a
disgrace I mean any of you have traveled
to Europe and you've gone on the TGV or
these others that here we are in Silicon
Valley for Nia and we're still
struggling
to justify taking off our shoes on
Southwest Airlines to run to the airport
to then wait for you know the plane to
arrive to realize that we're an hour and
a half late to get on a flight that was
supposed to be 20 minutes to Fresno
that's an hour and a half because it has
to circle around I mean this is
ridiculous and so the high speed rail
and these rail systems are a big part I
think California's future and certainly
be a big part of the Bay Area's future a
couple questions on basically the role
of mayor and how Mayor Adam works one
from a Twitter question from B Guterres
what are the most permanent decisions a
mayor can make that's a great question
because the everything that's done can
be undone it's really true you pass
along one day you can rescind it the
next day
you know I say this all the time I'm the
future ex mayor of San Francisco that I
know and guys like me come and go I mean
they do I mean there been 41 others and
there'll be 41 hopefully if God's
willing next generations but principles
transcend values permeate and transcend
and when I think of San Francisco in
terms of the things that unite and the
things that are permanent its those
values I mean you think about it or 160
or so years old and the values were
really promulgated in San Francisco in
the mid 1850s with the discovery of gold
people came from all over the world for
riches and new beginnings a small
fishing village was literally turned
overnight to coast a quarter million
people from all over the world
talk about diversity and from that the
framework that exists today one of the
most diverse cities in the most diverse
region in the most diverse state in the
world's most diverse democracy and we
can say this proudly it's not perfect
and it's hardly exclusive but people are
living together and advancing together
and struggling to prosper together
across every conceivable difference and
it's because we don't just tolerate that
diversity we celebrate it and it's that
ability to reconcile our differences to
celebrate them but to unite around those
things that bind us together
that transcend that have been more
permanent in many respects than any
specific initiative or idea
it's the reason we're doing universal
healthcare
it's intuitive here so reason we have a
sick leave ordinance the reason we have
the highest minimum wage it's the reason
that we have a working families Tax
Credit and a strategy to get people out
of check cashing places into banking
strata into banks it's a reason we're
rebuilding our public housing long
overdue but finally reconciling it's the
reason we have the most aggressive
environmental program in America it's
the reason we have been there turns the
fight of HIV or an AIDS it's the reason
that we've led in terms of smoking
cessation it's the reason that we've
been the city we are and that's more
permanent and that's extraordinarily
proud of and that's hard to pinpoint and
that's the most important thing and that
goes to pride in spirit those
intangibles and so those values are the
thing that every single day I think
about how can we advance the values that
define this city and transcend this city
in terms of its leadership that's why
gay marriage was so obvious and
intuitive it was a principle of uniting
people that framework of equality that
notion again that we're all in this
together in that celebration of that
diversity and so again it was a natural
extension of the narrative that is the
story of San Francisco and I do think
there's permanence to that and I think
whoever your next mayor is your next
Board of Supervisors next governor
whoever the next president
San Francisco will if it continues to
remind itself of that proposition that
orientation that will continue to
permanently outperform on so many
different levels the rest of the state
in the nation here's a governance
question that comes up particularly in
context of good old New Urbanism which
partly was born in this area and the new
Urbanists want well especially Peter
Calthorpe wants Regents to be governed
not just City yeah and particularly San
Francisco is this rather small entity in
a rather large metropolitan area and now
demographers and city people talking
about what are called mega pollen areas
in our case reaching basically all
to Reno and there's one all the way down
the east coast and so on and this is
where a lot more than half the world is
now is in these mega pollen areas and
you know there's different watersheds
there's different counties there's state
lines that sometimes cut across these
things what have you found either in
your travels or in the way things are
progressing here and how regional
governments a lot of rhetorics you know
it's the big thing right I become mayor
we're gonna work more regionally
together and the other mayor say it and
then we show up and we have a great
press conference it's just great to be
working and we run back and nothing
really gets done I mean you see it over
and over again and here's why I mean
it's not I've dealt with two different
mayor's from San Jose two different
mayor's from Oakland and so I've done
all these print we did it on earthquake
and safety we did it on Regional Transit
we've done it on environmental
stewardship just a few weeks ago we've
done it on housing and they're fabric
sighted and we got a bag they're empty
all these regional agencies and everyone
shakes hands and we sign these great
things then we walk away and the reason
we do is because we're fighting for
money and we're fighting against each
other
Bart to San Jose it's great but Muni
light rail into Chinatown or a subway in
the Chinatown is what I'm after and so
by definition we're in a competitive
environment the challenge is then to
regionalize funding if you can
regionalize funding then you have true
regionalism and this is something that
needs to change dramatically in the
state of California it changed Stewart
as it relates to funding for homeland
security we used to have something
called uiz grants these urban area
grants now we have Suozzi grants these
super urban area grants and it was the
best thing that could have happened
not for San Francisco but for the San
Francisco Bay Area because we were
always more competitive when we're going
after those dollars with Nancy Pelosi
and Feinstein and boxer but then they
changed the funding where it said all of
you have to come together and you have
to put aside your differences and you've
got to prioritize your respective
efforts on for example interoperability
the bill
communicate across jurisdictions etc and
as a consequence we have real planning
we have very stressful strategies but at
the end of the day we have a framework
for a real dialogue MTC tries to do that
on transportation but again it's limited
it's not as comprehensive if you can
link funding you'll have to regionalism
I I always agree the idea they think
globally act locally plan regionally
that was always the piece that was
missing the plan regionally and that's
critical we're never gonna have enough
affordable housing in the city and
county we're never gonna solve
homelessness for everybody we have four
nine thousand plus people but we have
thousands more that have just arrived
without a regional approach we're never
going to ultimately address the
environment by definition it knows no
boundaries unless we have a regional and
I mean broadly regional approach so all
of these issues have to be dealt with in
advance it's like you're saying fund
regionally yeah so does that get done
from the federal level usually I guess
that happened with the anti-terror stuff
or was that stay I was mostly federal
dollars state state has the same thing
absolutely state needs to do the same
thing and and that's again it's what's
missing we're still stuck in these old
silos of 150 years ago I remember the
civil service system in San Francisco
was conceived at the turn of the century
the state of California last that big
Constitutional Convention everyone's
talking about last one we have eighteen
hundred and seventy eight I mean things
haven't dramatically changed I was
arguing I said GM's new strategists the
reason they got upset well there are a
lot of reasons I said your plan is just
about failing more efficiently I'm and
and so I find that we can argue the same
often times right I mean certainly the
educational debate in this country
certainly in the state so it requires
some order of magnitude change that's
why I like thinking in terms of just
reframing the entire debate even away
from what kind of vehicles to a new
model of delivering minutes or miles in
that case a new way of thinking that's
what defines the best of this region in
the spirit of the state actually one
more mayor question
I've noticed that cities that have able
to really been buckled down and able to
improve from decade to decade often keep
the same mayor for decade to decade
you've seen it in tandem so is term
limits for mayor's in San Francisco good
or bad I think it's a good thing I'm not
a big term limit fan but for executives
I am I think it's healthy III I Mayor
Bloomberg and I we've become you know I
won't say good friends but I have great
respect and admiration I was of course
having fun at his expense but he does
the same with me you know I thought it
was rather audacious this third term
extension though I'm candidly quite
pleased because I think you'll have an
outstanding third term but I don't think
it's the right thing I don't think it's
healthy thing even for the city of New
York I think change is good again it's
the importance is to recognize that
institutionally you've got to have some
impact if you want that change not to
denigrate or be turned back meaning you
want it I want it for example I did
something you probably two-thirds of you
in this room oppose care not cash it's a
profoundly significant change that I've
tried to institutionalize in 2,600 human
beings have the dignity of a key lock in
a door in a house because we had the
courage to dramatically change the way
we delivered a basic fundamental service
to homeless we try to buy our way out of
the problem before now we're trying to
solve the problem by focusing on housing
expansion it's hardly been perfect
but I'm trying to institutionalize that
through this direct access to housing
model so that when I'm gone at least
that permanency transcends but you know
at that point need me around you need
the next mayor to come up with a
different idea different profound way of
building on that and taking it to the
next level and I so I think it's good
you get stuck in a rut you know I'm five
years into this I'm having the same
meetings at the same time the year same
hour of the day and they haven't didn't
we oh that was a year ago but didn't we
hit all was two years ago
they say and it's to sorta you know
there's a you get into that
that's why it's it's important to get
folks out of that rut by getting new
folks in that question of homeless
raises the question of how San Francisco
doing in the economic downturn as we
call it well better than anybody else
with the fourth lowest unemployment and
of the 58 counties in the state of
California our bond rating was raised as
the state of Californians was lowered
below Louisiana the lowest in the United
States
ours was raised we have add a need a
reserve it allowed us to care of every
teacher that was laid off and it's gonna
last draw down about forty nine million
dollars to help offset some of these
cuts that we'd otherwise experienced
because of our deficit we have a city
that has high unemployment but again
compared to Los Angeles other parts the
state's not even close
we are the birthplace of biotech and
life sciences but we had only one
biotech company five years ago now we
have 47 Pfizer just announced their bio
innovation biotherapeutics Center coming
into San Francisco anchored by Gladstone
and qb3 and now of course the California
stem cell Institute digital media
digital arts not just Lucas and ILM but
orphanage and others are out here Miss
Erica berry the green tech companies at
197 now we did tax incentives for green
tech tax incentives for biotech and life
science we got Wikipedia to move their
headquarters here we got Sun tech the
largest photo voto the photovoltaic
manufacturer in the world now to move
their American North American
headquarters here we've been very we
remember we were it used to be a
headquarter city but increasingly that's
the case it's not the Chevron's anymore
and I don't think that's terrible thing
in some respects or the be of a s
especially under the circumstances B of
a it can hold us hostage cities but it's
these smaller companies the Second Life
type companies it's getting Google to
bring their creative workers in to San
Francisco these are the reasons Stewart
we're doing better in terms of
unemployment in the economy than our
peer thirties yeah this was a question
and for Kathleen looks like do him she's
raising the question of the basically
how employees can live in these startups
here's typically startups can't pay all
that much
at work well we it's such a timely
question we put together a local
stimulus plan occur to me you hear all
this the federal government's doing a
Simmons plan here's California with a
two trillion dollar used to be a two
trillion dollar economy two trillion
dollar economy there wasn't no you know
my friend David Crane who works for the
governor called me when I said that on a
show the other day so we have one and
David has been doing a good job for the
governor but I just feel like the state
should be doing more in terms of
economic stimulus and recovery doesn't
mean just printing money there are other
things to do and so we put together 15
specific strategies for a local economic
stimulus and they're very detailed and
one of them answers that question with
all of this new vacant space coming up
how can we get nonprofits and how can we
get small startups to create incubator
opportunities and we're doing just that
through what we call our marketplace
initiative I won't bore you it's all on
our website that walks through in detail
what that means and how we can get
people into these spaces and how we can
incubate small startups in life sciences
and biotech which by the way we're about
to make an announcement there of some
new incubator strategy but also in other
high tech areas well a question like
that I've run into in various places
I mean Portland famous Green City the
Pearl District is either once again
poorly in that faith I tell you a
problem they have hurts you can tell me
how you don't have it here but I bet you
the Pearl District in Portland so you
know they've got Ecotrust base there is
a new green part of town they've got the
trolley coming through and they can't
get families because they can't get
families with kids not because they
can't afford it but because the good
schools are out in the suburbs where
everybody went some while ago they can't
get a good school in town so they can't
get the families how do we deal with
that well we have some great schools not
good schools in San Fran school and I
want you to know this and you probably
know you know the body you probably
don't live here because you moved out I
mean look at San Francisco just to see
whoa that is remarkable
these are constituents mayor yeah
well first of all thank you very much
for being here I this is one of the most
impressive audiences I've had a chance
but with a top performing urban School
District in the state of California
seven years in a row of improved test
scores if you get into Lowell or Lincoln
or Washington you're some of the best
high schools in America the challenge is
not all schools are like Lincoln law in
Washington so there's tremendous
disparity we're failing
african-americans Latinos the
achievement gap is deplorable but it is
almost everywhere else in the country
especially in urban centers every year
though we're making progress you may not
know this but I'm very proud of this we
have a partnership with our public
schools we call it a partnership for
achievement that's rhetorical let me
give you the substance we're the only
city in the state of California that
does universal preschool we're the only
big city in America Denver has a version
that has done it successfully and
comprehensively we value early child
education you want to get serious about
the achievement gap and graduation rates
you want to lower your truancy and
dropout rates focus on early childhood
education this city is a model for the
nation in terms of that work that
doesn't pay off overnight but that
return on investment is anywhere from
seven to ten dollars depending on the
study and it will pay great dividends
over the course of the next decade or
two we put arts education back into
every school every child every classroom
has comprehensive arts education the
city you funded it even though the state
is the primary funding source for
education we put doctors back into all
our schools we call them wellness
centers we opened up to deal with
physical health as well as adolescent
mental health needs we're putting these
edible school gardens in we're doing
composting we've got kids 25 salad bars
the city funded we're doing salad bars
kids are literally eating broccoli I
don't know if they know what they're
doing
in these public schools we have an
audacious idea we value I believe in
pre-k to 16 I think this K through 12
taught and that's just something's needs
to be thrown out
we now have done something we did this
the other day we had a graduation
ceremony for 420 of our 3,500 6th
graders and we gave them certificates of
guarantee guaranteeing every single one
of those 6th graders a four-year college
education we're doing that for all of
our 6th graders in our public schools
tell me a city in this country that does
that pre-k to 16 we guaranteed I just
told you 24 point five million dollars
we shifted over this year or committed
to it we'll go out in a few months so
that all those layoffs or at least I
think it was 80 plus percent of the
layoffs were rescinded from the school
district and we're hoping to get the
rest in the next few months so no
teachers were laid off you just
supported giving teacher raises last
year five thousand dollars across the
board roughly and then an additional
incentive if you work in low performing
schools and hard to teach subjects and
new strategies to support more
professional development of our teachers
what city has done that it's a very
exciting strategy and it's an exciting
time for public schools in San Francisco
I know it doesn't feel that way
and I know it's frustrating I know the
assignment strategy is antiquated and
getting your kids in the school choice
is almost impossible and I know how many
of you have threatened your friends and
family to leave to go down to Walnut
Creek or do what my mother did which is
move us to Corte Madera and that's why I
went to Redwood high school and not
where she went law of course there's
another reason I could never have gotten
in the wall and she was smarter than I'm
but nonetheless this remains one of a
big in challenging and vexing issues of
our time there's no more important issue
in the state of California than human
capital on the investment in people and
human beings it's been our godsend
it's the reason California matter
the reason San Francisco matters talent
people fibrin moves into San Francisco
and five prime therapeutics they move
into the city for one reason it was
cheaper to do business here not because
it's cheaper to do business here but it
was cheaper to do business here because
so many of their employees came from
here and it cost too much to relocate
them so they might as well be in the
city where they had the talent that's
why Google moved 600 plus jobs into San
Francisco because they were shipping
them all down it was costing millions
they might as well have them here that's
why Microsoft moved in and Yahoo's
expanded with their design firms Talent
if we stop investing in people and
talent this state is in serious trouble
and that investment starts in preschool
that investment advances through K
through 12 into institutions of higher
learning and that's the focus of any
successful sustainable community not
just cities but it rural and suburban
areas as well ok here's a couple of
constituents I question hey thank you
take about Jennifer berry says I've been
told it is illegal for San Franciscans
to collect rainwater for their
landscapes is true boy and you know what
I'm gonna I'm it can't be and if it is I
need to fix that particularly because of
this I went out with the PUC a few
months ago into our public schools and
there and we actually are giving our
public schools these new rainwater
collections systems so if I'm promoting
it on one hand and we had all the kids
out there and little kids and they
learned on the roof and then they're
their dates anyway it's just a sweet I
go every week I visit one or two schools
I joke with a school board I've been to
more schools than any of the school
board members and it's just one again
big passion of mine but the rainwater
collection absolutely should be we're
doing we have done lousy job at
recycling water and that's inexcusable
and mark my words in a couple of years
there'll be no one doing a better job
than recycling water then San Francisco
so rainwater is a big part of that and
so this is true can I steal that yeah
I'm gonna fix that and
if indeed there's problems with them
okay that sounds like it is a problem so
all right now thank you another
constituent question do you think more
difficult building standards will drive
even more people to build illegally how
do we encourage green building and
unpermitted construction oh because
green it doesn't cost that much more
it's a myth I mean let's see if there's
not been a study that's come out on
green buildings that hasn't proven to
things it cost less to operate it is
higher value it's cheaper to insure and
for those in the commercial sector you
get to benefits higher rents and a more
productive workforce why is anyone
building with non recycled material in
energy inefficient ways it makes no
sense the fact that we have to mandate
it is perverse and I actually think our
mandates are too modest even though
they're higher again than any other
cities so no I don't think it's gonna
drive people to build illegally getting
to LEED Platinum standards like the new
conservatory or the new Academy of
Sciences tough you know it's more
difficult to a living roof but to do
things that just beg common sense is not
something that people need to do
illegally getting energy-efficient
lightbulbs is one of the great
no-brainers of our day we had a thing we
call something called energy watch we
just rolled it out it put another 3.7
million dollars up it's not just all
cuts this year don't believe the press
and we're going out into businesses we
went to I don't want to promote but I'm
going to Lombardi sports kind of an old
San Francisco institution these guys
will save and they had no idea they're
just right up on I guess Polk Street not
so many blocks from us you have an
impressive sense of where things are no
our speakers don't know where North is
but but these guys just got the
advantage of our energy watch program
gonna say I think it was 40 some $1000
this year and I said where have you been
the last decade he started doing the
math half a million dollars he could
have saved if he just flipped out his
lightbulbs we're actually getting so
aggressive this is fun
we've moved so far beyond that
incandescent CFL thinks now we're about
to ban certain kinds of CFLs see it's
just one thing to talk about CFLs it's
the old t12 those big tubes we want to
ban those so you have t8 and I was with
Manny Diaz in Florida the other day
again getting inspired he says we're
gonna ban t8 and only duty 5s so which I
am going to be sending him a letter
tomorrow saying big mistake because
there's reasons you don't want to ban t8
s then I won't waste your time on but
nonetheless I liked his thinking a
competitive speak thinking but we're
actually getting into even more
prescriptive strategies in terms of
encouraging the right kind of energy
efficiency as opposed to the bad kind of
energy efficiency do more ways to have
fun as mayor two more questions
one twittered from Steve Midgley higher
density cities can be more energy
efficient than low density would have
San Francisco's plan for density
Manhattan is probably greener in that
sense than any other city in the US and
one of the greenest in the world
yeah well density is environmentally
shrewd and sound no question about it
sprawl is self-evident in terms of not
only just the inefficiency but the lack
of density requires more miles traveled
and it requires more energy consumption
by definition so it's absolutely right
misses the challenge isn't it this is
the challenge when I talked to my dad
who says Gavin when your grandfather was
here the skyline did not look like this
how could you have allowed that Rincon
tower to be built what have you done to
the beautiful skyline was driving in
over the Bay Bridge I couldn't believe
my eyes
when did that get built he said I said
well dad it's a strata we have 15 years
of planning it went through an advisory
strategy the community was big part of
it and it's part of our new urbanization
and it's you're the one that's the
environmentalists and the family
you know this is what you taught me that
density matters in its smart growth it's
around the transit corridors right now a
number of bus station will be right near
the new again the new Grand Central
Station on the west coast Transbay
terminal and this is what we're doing
and this is controversial we're doing
higher density we're doing taller
buildings we're not going to destroy the
neighborhood's we're not going my
friends on West Portal that are showing
me pictures of high rises on Westport
we're not doing high rises we're not
gonna be doing here on Chestnut Street
you know people I know are nervous we're
gonna keep the unique character that
defines the best of our neighborhoods we
understand the cultural competency that
character that makes this city not
anywhere USA makes every single district
something special but in the downtown
core in this new extended downtown
towards rink on Hill we're gonna allow
for more density and we think that's a
smart strategy so we can grow our
population which incidentally has grown
by over a hundred thousand since the
last census we actually appealed our
census and it's now at eight hundred
thousand seven ninety nine and we think
they are still wildly under County we
think we're closer than nine hundred
thousand and when the new census data
comes we're gonna be very aggressive on
that I think you'll see a number closer
that's so we're getting back to the
state of foggy like that because they
don't count everybody there's no
incentive to count cost this federal
government more money to count everybody
appropriately improperly I actually we
hired firm to come out called do a drill
down and they drill down and did real
cross analysis PG&E bills they did cable
bills they did they cross-referenced it
they found literally 97 I think it was
96 or 97 thousand more Sam school
residents and this is certifiable I mean
absolutely real and we went to the
Census Bureau and we realized we had
never appealed our census data
California doesn't do this other small
states appeal census data all the time
why do they do it smart all that federal
money what sorry about tens of millions
of dollars and I didn't know a city
candidly ignorance this is the downside
of I mean
you don't always know everything and he
sir III do know what I don't know which
is an enormous amount and that's the
good thing about being here for five or
eight years but we appealed it and we
actually won but what happens is they
have to take population away from other
cities or states so I don't yeah
Portland yeah Portland had a decline of
40,000 and/or at 800,000 so we went up
and by the way that all that is all that
all the new federal stimulus dollars all
those those per capita dollars
beneficiaries I mean we're talking
millions of dollars of good news already
our competitive grants we use this new
census data so this is a big big deal
transportation dollars those are worried
about Muni those are transportation
dollars that are notably on a formula
basis and these are going to so we're
going to be very good one of the things
by the way I'm sorry on this on census
this is insidious because of marriage
gay marriage they don't accept or
acknowledged married couples so if you
were legally married and you say you're
married the computer even if you locally
do it the computer national computer
will override that if it's same-sex
they're not going to count all gay
couples we have somebody named Ryan do
they know that that's a female I mean
well that's a point to know but it's a
strange again it this is get this whole
issue of the rights movement and how
long it takes to ultimately get things
right this is a big issue that we're
pushing and Mayor Bloomberg again we do
this left coast why right coast hits
we're doing these joint letters City
Council in New York and we'll be doing
the same thing here in San Francisco to
try to fight this okay last question
probably one you haven't had before this
is from Kevin Kelly what is the biggest
hurdle for San Francisco in the next
10,000 years and what are you gonna do
about it
earthquakes 10,000 years then then
you're worried about that one inch
becoming one foot or three foot tectonic
plate movie and so that makes me think
density may not be the smartest thing
right yeah gotten closer to the ground
so I'm arguing both sides of sea-level
rise you ready for the sea level no they
can and that was always gonna answer
look it's clearly global climate as
Friedman says disruption
it's the seriousness to which we all
should take the sea level rise which
incidentally is already happening there
was a study that came out that at the
Golden Gate Bridge it showed I I don't
want to be quoted but I think it showed
either four or six inches higher than it
was a century ago say Andrew what did
you have on that what was it 12 inches
okay you go back 150 years so already
and this is when things are going pretty
well right
and now the consciousness the last 50
years and and you got what six point
seven billion people nine point two
billion 10,000 years my gosh where would
be and so it clearly is climate change
so we got to get serious it's as if you
know I'm really worried a cap-and-trade
looks like it's it's it's going away I
mean I can't even Obama started sort of
softening on cap and trade and no one
was the guts to do a carbon tax because
you're gonna be out of office you think
gay marriages controversial do a carbon
tax in this climate listen to Sean
Hannity's thoughts on that or O'Reilly
so it's it means but something this is
serious cities can't just Ottoman samus
coats great in Portland and you know
this is serious and this is alarming and
it needs real national leadership and
with respect there's no bigger crisis
with even respect to this financial
crisis than the environmental crisis and
if cap-and-trade goes away if we don't
have that we're in serious peril you see
the stats you see the numbers and you
just saw two days ago or if there was it
last week the end of the week the new
model so the polar
caps again it's every single one of
these reports shows things much worse
than even the pessimistic estimates in
terms of the snowmelt and the seasonal
components of new ice creation as well
and so I just think you know as van says
save the polar bears and save ourselves
and that's a big call to all of us and
that's the opportunity to link it to the
economy and Link it to environmental
justice and income inequality and race
and that's why I again maintain my
optimism even 10,000 years from now when
Stuart's clock continues to tick thank
you all very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]